all right hey everybody welcome back
into my temporary lair for the week we
are standing by for a donald trump
press conference at the bottom of the
hour
you guys will not believe what i did for
you since my first stream
kind of browned out from the standpoint
of youtube earlier
um i tried to stream well i did stream
earlier
the kaylee mcinanny press briefing as
you can see i'm in a different
location i'm in a bunker this week and
the youtube stream just wasn't working
right now
i thought it must be because i'm using
different equipment but then i realized
all the settings for my streams are on
the cloud they're on youtube
they're on restream it doesn't really
make sense that it would be
equipment related now huge
shout out to my youtube rep who
immediately got me in touch
with someone on the tech side at youtube
with streaming we did a screen share
and what we determined this is
unbelievable for months
i've been using wait for it a deprecated
put that on trump's speech see if he can
get that word out i've been using
a deprecated um streaming
element for lack of a better term when i
stream to youtube through restream
and it's only by sheer luck that i've
even
been able to stream at all for the last
three months on youtube so all of these
youtube streams
they've been hanging by a thread not to
my knowledge because i'm supposed to use
a whole different infrastructure
needless to say
the new infrastructure as many of you
saw
pops up before i start something that
says i'm about to stream
and there were 4 000 people waiting for
me
can you imagine 4 000 people on youtube
waiting for me to start
and i think this is maybe the way to go
because we've already got 6 300 people
watching on youtube
nothing has happened yet
sorry i had to rebuffer there um so
anyway
i hope that that's fixed things are
beautiful
over on twitch things are perfect
on facebook so i think we're in for a
very very good stream the other issue i
was having
earlier was i couldn't see super chats
and if you can't see super chats i might
as well throw my laptop in the trash and
walk away right
uh because i see waller is me talking
about hopefully trump will be out soon i
see
sinful solutions shocked that we have
reached
900 and hold on
nine hundred and thirty thousand
so that's like seven syllables
subscribers on youtube
um sinful solutions asking have i been
to
thailand and that it's nice this time of
year um
so i was not able to see those easily
before now i can
and it's fantastic so i am very very
pleased
with how things are going recently
i want to say thanks to emeronic for
subscribing with twitch prime
trisha eastman has subscribed michael
eartube has subscribed and also
you know one thing i did is i have a
very powerful connection
at my normal studio we're talking giga
giga
you understand what i'm saying it's like
a giga giga connection
and i'm streaming in hd and all this
stuff i did
sort of turn down the stream quality a
tiny bit
for this stream i think it'll be better
i think it'll be better for us overall
um let's see here oh did we just get hit
with a raid
oh levy rosman hit me with a powerful
raid of 2896 people on twitch hey to
everybody
yet levy and i have been as i was just
describing my huge stream problems
we were scheduled to do a stream last
night and then we were looking at today
and the reason we had to pause my
training for pog champs too
is that entire five-minute rant i just
gave about all of my streaming problems
today
that was why i said to levy i'm deep in
tech hell i'm like trying to dig out of
tech hell
um so let's pause it because i it would
be hugely embarrassing to me in front of
uh the levy community
if we uh if i browned out during
during a a co-stream with levy
i don't know that i would ever recover
so hopefully we're going to be able to
put all of that back together very very
soon so welcome to all of
gotham chess's viewers over
on uh twitch as the hype train
is leaving the station um okay a lot of
people
asking about what's going on with sam
cedar and me
b-boy chi just spent two dollars to tell
me that sam cedar is better than me
okay well listen you just sent me two
dollars so i must be doing something
sort of okay um
do i have memes i do i did have some
memes stack up from over the weekend so
let's look at those
there's just a lot going on today a lot
a lot a lot going on today
um where do we want to go first maybe we
will go to memes
yeah this i need to get the super chat
overlay at the bottom of the screen i
can still see them
there's just no really easy way to do it
because i'm limited to
two monitors i'm gonna try to get it
set up for tomorrow um
let me see there's one way sorry i just
hit my microphone there there's one way
i
might be able to do it give me a moment
i would like to have super chats up on
the screen and i feel like that is a
good incentive people like seeing
you know those things up on the screen
so let me see if i can do
it uh okay let me switch to this just
briefly um and then
i think i might be able to let's see how
i can do this
if i go i'm working on putting those up
on the screen let's take a look
it would be a huge victory if i was able
to do it
because it's just maybe i need to get an
additional monitor
nope it's not going to work okay yeah
i'm gonna have to figure out the right
way to do it with two monitors
um what would be great is if stream labs
had
a widget for super chat if they do
please email me about it because i'm not
aware of it but i i
i will try to get that set up for
tomorrow okay let's look at a few
different uh
of things elements that i have to play
for you there was a very ugly moment
the other day with stephen kenneth
destiny
bonnell ii and one of my chess coaches
alexandra botez you tell me what you
make of this
this seems like there's a little bit of
i don't know if we would call it
jealousy or envy but something seems a
little weird take a look at this
but hey listen i hope you have fun i
hope you have fun with your new best
friend david pakman
playing in pogchamps okay i hope you
guys uh have a great time over there and
i'll just be over here getting dumped
by my fiance you [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
pretty aggressive
um i didn't like i i don't like how
destiny
he seems rattled and on tilt quite
frankly by the fact that alexander has
been coaching me
it's weird it's weird and i'm gonna have
to probably get a hold of him and see if
we can clear some of that up because
that's a very
i don't want things going in that
direction with steven
and um you know i just think we have to
be very very careful there
okay so we've got that other memes let's
see if i can put these up on the screen
yeah here we go let me see
there we go so this i received me trying
to understand
david pakman's discount some of these
discounts
are borderline illegal and
i know that they're essentially as clear
as
jonathan swann trying to understand
donald trump's various charts and graphs
so this is a good one this was sent to
me by somebody
i don't know exactly who um
oh level two hype train is happening
okay very a lot a lot of different
things
all right so anyway this is a good one
let's see what else we've got
clash of the titans whoa hold on a
second the fight for a million
subscribers
this viewer felt as though i was
sort of running away with the million
subscriber
fight with sam cedar um
and i don't know that that's the case at
all i mean we there's still a big fight
to be had
but okay that's not bad um
here let's take it let's zoom this one
in a little bit
here so trump hands jonathan swan one of
his pieces of paper swan looks confused
the paper says david is hiding a 10 inch
zucchini
jonathan swann looks confused and then
trump looks confused okay that's not bad
i kind of like that that's cool uh we'll
zoom it back out and then let me see if
i've got anything else
would you subscribe could you subscribe
won't
you help me neighbor mr pacman's
neighborhood uh mr rogers theme i like
that i grew up on mr rogers when i first
came to the united states in fact
um you know everybody talks about sesame
street
and sesame street's great but i
learned much more english early on from
mr rogers and actually the first episode
of mr rogers that i ever saw
was the one where they go to the crayon
factory
and to say that i was um visibly
flummoxed would be an understatement but
i learned a lot
so i think we want to remember mr rogers
just as important as sesame street and i
like that so all very very exciting and
good things
and i'm glad to have everybody here
right now everything seems to be working
very very well
huge thank you by the way to i'm
inconsolable
who has gifted 20 subscriptions if you
can believe it oh i'm so sorry
i uh did not turn down my phone and
somebody's very very angry with me right
now
okay thank you very much we got that um
thank you to hiroranga and everybody
else for doing all of these extreme
sign ups and all of that i do want to
say thank you to
callan gardner who's new member number
one today
jamie lynn murray is new member number
two okay those graphics are working
leif hoffman is new member number three
jody anderson is number four
and jacob winning hello is new member
number five today awesome
all right everything's working
everything's working so far which is
great
what's my native language it's uh
spanish spanish is my native language
okay so we are standing by for a donald
trump
press briefing scheduled for the bottom
of the hour
um i did tweet earlier and a lot of
people i really a second
have responded very powerfully to this
as you can see
60 000 likes on this tweet this is
today mark it down august 10
2020 what day is it august 10 2020
the most successful tweet i've ever had
isn't it weird how a coronavirus death
rate of one percent
is plenty low to open everything
but meanwhile voter fraud incidents of
point giga01
means end vote by mail
dr hugh laurie i'm sorry
hugh laurie who plays dr gregory house
on house md
following me triggered by this tweet
okay um a lot of really great people
michael zagan who uh plays
the guy in uh miss maisel
loving this tweet a lot of really really
great people um so that was that was a
good it's a we
i think we won the game today on twitch
which is very very important to me of
course
arbitrary measures of one's self-worth
are
uh much much much to be followed
squirrelyosis
testing my spanish capability
who says oh treating me very formally
with the uh
for formal designation puede hablar algo
de espanol
para
yes well i just did and please we can be
on informal terms i don't need to be
addressed with formal spanish
um certainly not necessary at all
bolo turner says via super chat desantis
says restaurant employees
don't need a negative covid test to
return to work can you imagine
it's florida it's florida so i can
imagine
jacob ratner asks david what is the best
way to deprogram someone from right-wing
propaganda on the virus
honestly if one is completely committed
to right-wing propaganda on the virus
sometimes the only way to deprogram them
is for them or someone they love to get
the virus and that's tragic it's truly
tragic
um but i've seen it i've seen it happen
and it can be very very ugly it's sort
of like
when a anti-gay republican
20 years of anti-gay in their background
their nephew is gay and they go you know
uh seeing how my nephew has been treated
made me rethink
well great okay but it would be nice if
it didn't require
some personal issue before you imagine
right like
could you imagine someone else whose
nephew is being discriminated against
and then maybe
you know you come to your own solution
robert fancy pants motorcycle mcgee
with a 100 argentinian peso super chat
my god
i've got a bunch of pesos left over from
my last visit to argentina
they're they're worth nothing it's
tragic says can we get a cukes and
zuke's update yeah
so i actually man i didn't want to br i
don't want to bring everybody down right
away
but my zucchini plant may be dying uh
i i did a little bit of research and it
seems as though the zucchini
plant some kind of uh disease
may have struck the zucchini plant after
getting only four or five
zuks out of it and i'm going to see when
i get back
to boston in the meantime though my
cukes are doing beautifully
and i already threw one into my pickle
brine and hopefully i will have
beautiful beautiful pickles when i get
back
some people want me to talk to hassan
[ __ ]
i don't know that we're going to do that
right now because we're expecting trump
relatively soon so we're not going to do
that quite yet
um i want to say thanks to khmer and get
some
braxton night coffee artistic simplicity
perturbo racing neophyte
and spudnik spudnik gifting 10 tier 1
community subscriptions
you know somebody wrote to me and told
me spudnik
is philip defranco and they've been
gifting a lot of subscriptions recently
i know philip follows me and we had a
beautiful exchange via twitter dm
recently
but i don't know that spudnik is philip
defranco a couple people told me that
and i don't know why
people think that but that's interesting
um okay well what can you do
planet bongosan says yo it's my actual
birthday little shout out to me and
other uk viewers please
dp thanks in advance pal yes happy
birthday to you
uh a big big thank you and welcome to
all uk viewers i was in the uk in
december
i would love to get back i have stories
from christmas
in the uk uh dinner
on christmas night christmas day
night you understand what i'm saying now
not christmas eve christmas day
in the evening at a kosher chinese
restaurant
in what's the name of that uh what's the
name of the london
uh jewish neighborhood it's like north
of london anybody know what i'm talking
about
i would no it's not not hempstead what
is the name
not glasgow no no not hatton gardens not
tottenham
not brookshire no
it's not northampton nope nope nope nope
hendon could it be hendon is that is
that a thing
okay we don't know anyway i had a great
dinner
um hemel hendon
hendon yes exactly that is it hendon
great dinner on um
christmas eve evening in um
london december would love to get back
there gabe g says would you ever
join tyt so my youtube channel actually
was part of the tyt network until
january
we separated because i decided it's just
better for me to build my own brand
independent of anybody else's brand it
was the right decision
and uh we've never looked back merely
from the standpoint of independence not
because of anything about
tyt thanks to nato jenkins tv
for gifting five community subscriptions
a lot of really great questions are
coming in via super chat chris rickard
points out that in georgia
200 school kids are in quarantine and
republican circles are claiming victory
what's the victory yeah i don't see the
victory of quarantining students the day
after they go back
um what else do we have here a lot of
different super chats coming in
waffles giraffes asking how could you
how could i
see trump in a new light at this point
if trump cures cancer
you know i mean that's certainly
something it looks like i'm a little
dark today
let me adjust the light a little bit i
do have a window
i could crack but yeah the lighting is
definitely tough at this time of day
doing the best i can my friends a few
other thank yous
rich doran is new member number six
today on my website
stephen alcock is number seven
today kailyn gardner is new member
number eight
thanks kaelin callan i'm sorry
callan i apologize for that um
we are standing by for donald trump at
the bottom of the hour you might
remember
actually i have video let me pull up
some video while we have time
over the weekend donald trump gave these
wacky
gong show press briefings where they
were at his club
in bedminster and he actually had like a
crowd
of supporters cheering when
um he said certain things and booing the
media it was
really weird let's just look at one one
video this is our friend cbs
reporter paula reed who
confronted donald trump about the fact
that he keeps taking credit for veterans
choice
that's barack obama's 2014 bill has
nothing to do with donald trump
when she pressed him on it he abruptly
ended the press briefing and walked away
so by the way that's trump telling paula
reed she's finished
and that's it and the crowd cheers these
people are sick
[Applause]
it was passed in 20 excuse me go ahead
and please a false statement sir
okay thank you very much everybody thank
you very much
and then this is a much more you can see
that when trump has watched
[Applause]
um whenever trump has the benefit of of
a crowd
that is friendly to him he takes on sort
of a bully confidence and this is how
these guys operate this is what they're
used to
bull even bullies in like middle school
elementary school
part of what they feed off of is energy
from people around them and that's very
very much the case with donald trump and
you can actually see him feed off of the
crowd
cheering and it's a much more confident
trump uh in any case
just you know that this is this is uh
he he cares very little and respects
very little
um about the media and i don't think it
should come as a surprise to any of us
that when he is actually confronted and
can't run away like with jonathan swann
he completely and utterly implodes
okay thanks to 24 pounds
for subscribing with the message steven
kenneth destiny bonnell the second
thanks to little blue doggy also for the
twitch prime subscription
samuel lopez asks donde esta
david where am i well this is what i can
tell you
it's a pandemic and massachusetts is
handling
it very well so i'm not leaving
massachusetts
um at this point in time
other super chats let's see here
unknown says could trump make himself
the fifth head on mount rushmore
no no no no i don't think so i don't
think so
um emmanuel kant says i hope trump is
asked about his wish to be engraved on
mount rushmore what a freak show yeah
there are reports that trump had
staffers reach out to actually the
governor of south dakota
to inquire no other campaign oh my god
to inquire about putting his uh head on
mount rushmore trump is denying the
story as a fake
phony news story looks like we're going
to get live video in the room yes here
we are so the tvs are already set up and
and hopefully this will start relatively
soon
i also want to say thanks to justin
victory justin victory is new member
number nine today at joinedpakman.com
if you will give me just 45 seconds
i do want to remind you everything we do
the broadcast show the podcast the pog
champs the streams staff health
insurance
everything you understand is funded
primarily
by people who just grab a membership on
my website now i don't want your last
dollar
i don't want your last two dollars if
you are suffering because of
the virus the show is here we're going
to continue doing it it's free for
everybody
but if you are in the umbrella of people
who can afford two bucks a month or a
dollar eighty consider getting
this membership here join pacman.com
coupon code 2020 now
saves you 66 that
you are every we estimate about 0.6
of our audience subscribes meaning every
member
is essentially subsidizing the show
for 200 people you understand the math
okay so um i will thank everybody who
signs up i really appreciate everybody
who has been signing up
i am going to count corey schutz just
made a pledge on patreon
we're counting everything if you prefer
to do it on patreon by all means
but the most direct place to support us
where we keep
almost all of every dollar is my website
we just pay 2.9 percent to swipe credit
and debit cards
and we swipe them powerfully
and respectfully okay and by all means
use the coupon code 2020 now if you want
if you want and you will save 66 i'm
going to
um maybe let's see if i can get a little
more light on in here
there we go oh that's beautiful we are
much better off i'm a little overexposed
now on this side but i think that's i'm
doing the best i can
with the lighting in the bunker today
but i love that
vinther1991 checks in from norway with a
super chat
thanks for your very important work i
appreciate that
thank you also rand says have been
seeing the right saying
this isn't a democracy it's a
constitutional republic anytime people
accuse trump of anti-democratic behavior
what is this about
i have videos on my youtube channel
about that deranged
disgusting talking point um i encourage
you
to check them out uh i think you will
find them instructive to say the least
uh book smarts has raided with a party
of seven on twitch which i appreciate
yeah it's i it's absolutely going to be
a cringe fest
today people predicting a cringe fest
are completely spot on
um okay other super chats that are
coming in
aquatic llamas says what time can we
call into your show i don't know what
time your live show is
there is no live show in the sense that
the podcast
that comes out every day at 3 p.m
eastern we record it
around noon but it's not live
uh if you want to call into the show we
typically take phone calls
wednesdays at 12 15 pm eastern time
the number is 617-830-4750 and just as a
heads up one thing that we have done
is limit the phone lines to just 35
slots we used to have situations where
like 80 people would be on hold
i'm never getting to 80 phone calls it
was just running up our phone bill
people were sitting on hold for an hour
furious then emailing me horrible things
about
my face and my body and just my
political views you know people furious
furious
so we've decided to limit the phone
lines to 35 phone lines uh
open at a time we can have 35 people
holding and then it'll just block you
you'll just bounce
so if you want to get in i recommend
calling a few minutes early
uh the number is 617-830-4750 and we
will be taking calls
wednesday at 12 15 p.m eastern time
um okay what else oh
okay i have a few a few people to thank
mac stamper is new member number 11
andy rizpale is new member number 12.
sean alex is number 13. david rosengren
is number 14 mike bros
is number 15
and then who else am i missing here i
know i'm missing someone
um schuyler morales
is number 16. joe truman
betty van hethoff and tim van slyke are
number
17 18 and 19
and then last but certainly not least
jesus
reyes is number 20.
uh oh and alex yanusky
is number 21 today very very much
happening there
should colleges reduce tuition prices
asked by katie bradshaw i i have two
thoughts on this
first of all if it's remote obviously
you shouldn't pay anything for room and
board
but you also shouldn't pay facilities
fees a lot of what
you pay not a lot significant amounts of
what students pay
are facility fees which are not strictly
speaking room and board
but they are for learning you know the
gym labs
etc obviously if you're if your college
is going remote you shouldn't have to
pay that
but in addition to that i actually do
believe that there is something
about being there in person and if
you're not there in person
i think there should be some discount to
tuition because the
um the the dynamics of the class are
different the dynamics of how you relate
to the teacher are different
that that's my personal perspective my
mom teaches college
she happens to agree with me um
so yes that is that is certainly my
perspective
alex asks via super chat how much of
conservatism is really just dishonest
language tricks it's it's a lot of it
it's a lot of it i mean but they're also
effective language tricks so
um george lakoff has written extensively
about this one just one example
where the language favors the simplistic
arguments of the right
is on taxes right there's a beautiful
simplicity
it's wrong but there's a beautiful
simplicity to the idea of
you earned the money it's your money
you should get to keep all of it or
almost all of it
that's great right because then the left
doesn't have an opposingly simple
argument
we have listen we live in a society and
we have the resources to ensure
that we don't have homelessness and we
don't have hunger and we want to
centralize the production of roads and
mail deliver right we're already in the
weeds and unfortunately most things in
life are not as simple as the right
wants to make them out to be
so it's a lot of semantics it's a lot of
overly simplistic arguments but they win
elections with this stuff that's the
reality so
we can complain about it but complaining
about it won't really
win elections for us we actually have to
be smart and think through
uh how we're going to fight it how we're
going to fight it thanks to spudnik19
for subscribing
wootix has gifted five subscriptions
on twitch which i very much appreciate
um
people are sending me messages about
pepe and yi
i don't get into it because my instinct
is there could be a lot of racism in
there so i'm very very careful about
talking about
pepe yi or any of that stuff uh want to
be really careful
mike bros says just want to say thank
you for pronouncing my last name
correctly most don't
my pleasure i love the last name bros
nothing better than that
um let's see if we're live over on the
white house feed yet not yet that's
weird
this actually may start relatively soon
which would be great
uh oh people want a social blade update
oh man people are really getting uh
people are really getting sucked into
the sam cedar can you imagine
uh sam cedar and i announce that we are
fighting to we're fighting a race to a
million subscribers
he immediately sinks to a completely new
low
and guest hosts on msnbc can you imagine
a cheaper
tactic to win than subscribing
than hosting on msnbc but let's see
where we are right now
if you we look at the recent few weeks
you will see that sam was actually ahead
of me he's the blue line here
and then we extremely powerfully surged
from behind
and i can tell you exactly what happened
we
um when we hit 900 i said to my audience
i need your help i want to get to a
million subscribers by election day
and then boom we just rocketed above and
beyond and we are now at
930 000 subscribers
let's get a projection we have a very
important key race projection as cnn
likes to say
we currently are projected by
socialblade
to reach 1 million youtube subscribers
on november 30th that is pretty damn
close to election day so we only need
we're close uh with just a little bit
more of a push
we should be able to move that up to
november 3rd which would be amazing
uh let's see exactly where we are today
we're we're almost at 9 31. actually we
have 17 000 people watching live on
youtube right now
if half of you aren't subscribers and
you subscribe
we will be at 935 000 like that
you understand what i'm saying right
that love that noise
um so yeah i'll give you guys an update
on where that is tomorrow but i think
it's very interesting
austin r says what do you think about
the massachusetts 4 district race to
replace joe kennedy's
seat who would you back i don't know
who's running in that one to be
perfectly frank
um i am i am voting for ed markey in
marky versus kennedy
but i don't know uh who's who's running
for that one
uh johann nielsen says thanks for the
great work that you're doing thank you
johan for the support
cooley mann says shouldn't we focus
overly simplistic
conservative talking points with
ridicule isn't that the only way to
disarm the right extremists
there's actually no one answer with some
people ridiculing ridiculous ideas
is the best way to disabuse them so to
speak with
others um you want to apply sort of a
respectful and empathetic socratic
method of questioning
there's a lot of different types of
people and some of them are beyond reach
quite frankly and so from an electoral
standpoint i actually think the best
strategy
to win elections is just to get out the
vote for people who already agree with
us half the country doesn't vote if i if
you say to me david
can you more quickly change the mind of
one trumpist or convince
five people to vote i think i can
convince five
leftists who don't vote to vote in less
time
than it would take me to change the mind
of one trump tool
so my approach has been oh the tvs just
went black
my approach has been let's just get the
vote out
more than arguing with people but
you know different people can certainly
disagree
with one perspective versus the other
other messages coming in via twitch um
not so many wutix has subscribed with
prime
individualism killed the cat has
subscribed
um we have enabled bttv emotes
over on twitch and if you have
other requests for emotes you want me to
enable from bt
tv please email me through my website
contact form
and tell me exactly what the name of the
emote is and i'm glad to enable them as
long as
i don't perceive that they are you know
racist or discriminatory
in some way we try to avoid that chris
rickard
has an interesting point he says the
most frustrating thing about
conservative voters
is that most don't seem to realize that
there's nothing conservative about
this republican party that's right this
current republican party
is a faux populist reactionary
perversion
um period i mean i don't i don't think i
necessarily need to say more
uh but absolutely danny thompson says
love the very powerful finger snapping
onward
to the one million youtube subscriber
goal yeah
absolutely we are very very much oh
somebody says we hit 9 31 is that true
oh my god we did wow
we just a second ago we were 600
subscribers from 9 31
and we are at 9 31 already unbelievable
uh feel akira says oh nice you got the
stream working again yeah stream is
working beautifully
and we are standing by for donald trump
as we speak b boychi
says how do you feel about using
republican tactics against
trump like the lincoln project here's my
view about the lincoln project
these are republicans who will go right
back
to being anti-democratic republicans the
day
donald trump leaves office so if you're
asking me
should we welcome money that is pouring
in to pretty good videos that are going
to antagonize and trigger donald trump
of course
but i did a story last week called
are anti-trump republicans their own
party
the answer is no as soon as donald trump
is done
whether that's in january or january of
2025
these republicans you know people like
uh george
george conway yeah george conway
kellyanne's husband um
steve schmidt who else the florida
guy that i've interviewed before you
know all of them
they immediately go back to being
basically like romney-type republicans
and so i understand that given the
absurdity of the trump administration to
many of us
mitt romney feels dramatically less
offensive all of a sudden and
certainly it's true right things exist
on a spectrum if you say to me
much like if you say to me do i prefer
biden or trump i say i prefer biden
if you say do i prefer romney or trump i
prefer romney right that
we harm reduction is a real thing any of
us pretending
that uh in the future people
you know like george lifelong
republicans are going to be on our side
in making the country more progressive
in any real way
dealing with the systemic issues that
are the big issues facing
now they go right back to it and a lot
rick wilson is the other guy
and a lot of them are doing this for
personal gain as well
that's something important to remember
welcome to our good friend
uh grand master benjamin feingold
uh careful with that fianchetto ben but
he cheers 99 bits which i love
constructive insult has subscribed with
prime
pv usher says thank you for your very
powerful coverage of trump david
it is one of the best everyone is saying
this yes in very trumpian language
i will take the praise uh
cg says got time for a game on chess.com
quick no no no i'm playing only high
quality high quality games right now
because i am in training for pog
champs too so uh and i think this is
probably going to start momentarily
i do want to thank a few other new
members william petty is number 22.
marissa tarasevic or terezovic
is number 23. matthew malapaya
is number 24. michael o'neill is number
25 and you know as i like to say when we
get to 25 let's go for 50.
sarah harrington is number 26
thankfully i'm canadian is number 27.
um and anthony gray
is number 28. did i miss anybody i don't
want to miss anybody
oh um miles anton
mark islik are numbers
29 and 30.
very good appreciate that
uh okay other super chats that are
coming in
sam dean checking in from australia
g'day dave
victorian premier or premier
daniel andrews to face inquiry today
over bad covered or coveted response
resulting in 313 total deaths what a
cultural difference
it's uh completely stunning let me see
what the numbers are
today in the united states i have not
yet looked at them
i i fear looking at the numbers we are
of course over 5.2 million cases now
you know officially we're at 166 000
deaths new york times analysis of cdc
data
suggests we have under counted deaths by
at least
54 000 looking at an excess deaths model
so far 36 000 new cases today
383 deaths and at this point to be
perfectly frank
i don't know that we can trust any of
the data
um we have more reporters coming in
okay we're live now on the white house
feed i prefer this feed myself
uh oh you know what i don't have on this
computer
that's a problem i don't have volume
master which sometimes i need let me see
volume
master chrome
i want to bring you perfect
audio during these uh so let me see if i
can very quickly install
that extension on this computer
and very good oh okay i think we got it
alright so now let's see if i've got it
here where is volume master is this it
a lot of weird things going on
volume master there it is
ah beautiful look at that
good so if needed i am going to be able
to just
fine tune with a velvet glove
the um exact audio levels that we need
now the only thing i'm concerned about
is i don't know that we're getting there
should be some live audio here
i don't want to miss a second of this
let me make sure if we're good
we seem to be good let me just see here
okay we do have audio i think it's just
not live yet on the white house feed
very good
i think we're very very close um
okay excellent excellent excellent
excellent things are going very well
jesse cutter says i'm a covid i-c-u-r-n
i don't think i could handle the stress
of your job right now seriously thank
you for what you do
love from los angeles no no no jesse i
sit around playing on my computer
okay you are dealing with coronavirus
patients in an icu
in my mind i can't imagine the stress of
your job
but i do of course appreciate the
support
ben g says i love you david but i'd like
to see you call out more neoliberal bs
like crystal ball and cigar do cheers
oh boy all right micah gelfand
says you're all right david a bit of a
normie
betta cuck soy boy but you're still a
mensch
in my book ah well lechayam
is i think all i can say here is a
series
of clowns coming in and i expect we will
see donald trump very very soon remember
we are in a battle
against sam cedar to 1 million youtube
subscribers
i do ask with complete humility and
peace and love
absolutely smash that subscribe button
let's get to 932
000 we're almost there we've got 20 000
people watching on youtube
let's do it together let's get to a
million and
just you wait to see what we have
planned for when we get to a million
um thanks to reggienerd by the way for
subscribing for five months at tier one
the presence of steven mnuchin in the
room makes me think
that we are going to hear a lot about
unemployment and more of trump's visible
confusion with simple arithmetic
uh that that would be my guess i don't
know who these other two gentlemen are
and i use that term very loosely but my
sense is a lot of the questions today
and a lot of trump's diatribe
is going to be related to um
the unemployment stimulus etc okay yeah
so
um i have a super chat here from ferzie
who says david consider pausing instead
of muting i tried that during my kaylee
mcgannony stream earlier and i am going
to try that here so
i i will instead of muting i will pause
to interject
we'll see if people like it i you know
we'll we'll see i won't do it too much
all right here we go here is the mango
menace the tangerine terror
a golf twitter as we call him
i thought i'd start by talking about
some mail-in voting that just was
revealed just the news half a million
incorrect
talking about hd mail in voting that
just was
revealed just the news half a million
incorrect
absentee ballot applications were sent
all across
the state of virginia including to
many dead people this was an
unprecedented mailing flub
that's heightened concerns about okay
low-energy benzo trump
integrity of expanding mail-in voting
and mail-in voting efforts
it's a disaster all over virginia half a
million votes
so that's something you have to think
about so remember nobody
returned fraudulent ballots uh it sounds
like we figured it out this is like
saying don't build houses because smoke
detectors
sometimes detect a fire we don't want to
have a rigged election
i know that and you have to be very
careful when you mention
as you constantly do russia russia you
mentioned
china or iran or others that attack our
election system and when you have this
mail-in voting it's a it's very
susceptible it's
something that can be easily attacked by
foreign countries and by frankly
democrats trump mentions foreign
countries and yet has done nothing to
stop foreign meddling and is just using
this to claim
that we shouldn't have vote by mail to
help himself threats and by republicans
and i think that it's something you have
to start thinking about very seriously
our system is not equipped for it the
post office is not equipped for it
post office has made it clear they are
equipped unless trump kneecaps them
and makes them unable to be equipped and
people should vote like they did in
world war one and
world war ii and your numbers will be
in 90 days or less your numbers will be
very good i think much better on the
coronavirus
remember he said in april 15 cases would
soon be zero
no predictions on cases from him are
worth anything the china virus
but it's something you have to look
about look at and and say this is just
crazy this just came out half a million
incorrect ballot applications sent all
over the state of virginia to
incorrect is not fraud weren't living
they had some
sent to pets dogs this is what we're
going to get into
and it's going to be a disaster and it's
going to be thought of very poorly
it's going to hurt our country
after our news conference saturday night
and the pro
growth announcement were pro-jobs
pro-health safety
executive orders the stock market
went up 358 points today so we
we issued those executive orders and
nasdaq down the stock market went up 358
points today it's quite a reaction the
dow jones
and the s p 500 are now up 50 percent
since march 50 thank you okay people
don't seem to like pausing so i will
just
briefly mute as needed the nasdaq index
continues to set new records it's been
up
over 14 times new record in nasdaq
and uh the s p 500 and the dow
dow jones are going to be i mean the way
they're going
it looks like they're just about going
to be topping records hopefully soon
excuse me what's going on
uh-oh something's happening they're
pulling trump out
is there some kind of threat trump has
just been pulled out
we have no idea what happened okay guys
let's figure out what's going on trump
has just been pulled out it looked like
for security reasons
um
oh people are running now people seem to
be very urgently leaving
press briefing room cleared let's see
what's going on
huh
guys this seems to be breaking news but
you can all
try to help me figure out what's going
on but we have a cleared
abruptly cleared press briefing room
let's see what is going on
i'm not seeing anything quite yet but
this seems to be happening in real time
uh whoa the live stream has ended what
on earth
okay let's see what's going on here
people taking pictures of something
going on
outside there must be some disturbance
at the white house
press i'm tweeting now press briefing
room abruptly cleared and trump
just pulled out by secret
service anyone know what's going on
uh oh and programming will return
shortly wow
um i have no idea what shots fired
nearby
someone says let's see
still nothing that i'm seeing
if anybody can direct me to some
oh oh my goodness what is happening here
live stream ended let's go back to the
live feed
uh whoa all right well listen we're all
dealing with this in real time
um i have never seen this happen before
either
i'm following the chat cnn has it
shots fired let's see if i can find
some article okay cnn
see what's going on there
college football postponed anderson
cooper
baltimore explosion coveted coved
yeah i'm not seeing anything about it
still
msnbc okay let's see what msnbc has if
you're just joining us
after just about 90 seconds donald
trump's
press briefing was abruptly ended let me
see if i can pull up an msnbc feed here
uh i'll do it off screen just you know
just to be safe
and okay
let's see
i should have video for us very soon
we have no idea what's going on
now it's back to trump speaks oh my god
all right things are getting crazy yeah
i uh
fox is back on okay let's go back to fox
where is the live stream here with fox
not seeing it fox news
trump um
two days ago four hours ago 34 minutes
ago
that's something else
cbsn has it live okay let's see cbsn
trump live ah here we go
or a reporter uh to give us some sense
of what is being told
to journalists there in the briefing
room and around the white house grounds
but there you can see from that vantage
point anyway
it appears that it is cbs news it is it
is journalists rather white house
reporters photographers who are gathered
there
and they don't appear to be getting any
kind of uh update just yet everybody's
happening really just in the last few
minutes where we saw
president trump begin the briefing as we
have
just in recent days become accustomed to
seeing the president
do uh have these briefings in the five
o'clock eastern hour
and it was just a few minutes into that
process today
that he abruptly was told to leave the
briefing room we understand
from a cbs news producer by an agent
so we're going to continue to monitor
this picture for you and of course
bring you any information fox news
reporter john roberts who
is standing right here i think just
tweeted that shots fired near the white
house
and to that briefing we
are waiting to find out what exactly
may have taken place that would have
required the president to be removed
from
the briefing room there that's the scene
inside the briefing room photographers
again and journalists
assembled there just as soon as we get
some details we will bring that to you
wow turning to some other news it is now
a requirement to wear a mask outdoors in
parts of paris
okay let's see if we can get back to
some kind of live
feed i don't know if they plan to resume
or if they're going to have trump uh
hidden away
oh my god i'm sorry that that keeps
playing i'm just looking for whether
they've re
put up a new vid a new stream here they
have not
uh let's go back to fox
fox news trump live
um see news now from fox this
this scares me this might be like a
local news thing which i might get
dinged
might not be so good
okay at least this gives us a cent gives
us a sense of what's going on live in
the room
uh everybody reporting now it seems
quite a hubbub quite a hub up all right
well we'll wait a little bit
and see oh look at that interesting look
at all this stuff up here that's
interesting
um we're going to wait and see what
happens
fascinating let me see if i can find any
articles about what's going on now
secret service ends trump press
conference doors locked
see what we've got
a man who appeared to be secret service
just escorted trump out of the briefing
room
minutes into his briefing video clip
okay
yeah that doesn't really tell us that
much about what's going on of course
um let's see if cnn has any updated
information
yeah i guess we just don't really know
the full scope of it but it appears as
though it's shot shots fired ben stacy
twitter let's look at that
ben stacy twitter um
okay i don't know which one of these you
mean
it looks like i'm looking up random
people yeah
i don't know which one that is
he's back
i'm not seeing that let's see here he
has returned okay
let me see if we can uh oh
yep looks like it's now live again
wow they're
always quick and very effective work but
there was an
actual shooting and
somebody's been taken to the hospital i
don't know the condition of the person
it seems that the person was was shot
by secret service wow so we'll see what
happens and uh yeah
did you have something good
there are no details we just found out
just now
it was outside of the white house this
area right over
here and they'll have details anybody
think this is a stunt
somebody is taken to the hospital it
seems that the shooting was done by law
enforcement
at that person at the suspect it was the
suspect who was shot
and this just took place a couple of
people outside
i noticed a man named john roberts who
you know very well
he reported that he heard shots he was
outside and he heard
two shots
where were you taking mr president were
you taking to the bunker no we're taking
just out over to the oval office
uh just told me when he came up you
pretty much saw it like i did
he said sir could you please come with
me so you were surprised i was surprised
also i think it's probably pretty
unusual
but uh very very professional people
that do a fantastic job as you know
so it seems to me it seems to be from
what i was said there was
a shooting it was law enforcement
shot someone seems to be the suspect and
the suspect is now on the way to the
hospital
i can't tell you the condition of the
suspect
there was nobody else injured there was
no other law enforcement injured
and i just want to i will get onto the
press conference but
i i do want to thank secret service they
are fantastic the job they do
from what i understand the answer is yes
that's what i understand i don't know
you'll have to ask
what type of weapon
i don't know you'll have to get they'll
have they'll have a detailed
maybe a briefing for you outside later
i don't know i didn't ask that question
it might not have had anything to do
with me it might have been
something else but uh it was on the
outside of the premises the wall
the the as you know the fencing
especially the new fencing that they put
up is
very powerful powerful but it was on the
outside of the white house
okay and they'll have a full report
secret service
in a little while we'll have a full
[Music]
do i see him report yeah it's uh
unfortunate that this is
a world but the world's always been
a dangerous place it's not something
that you know the way he's talking about
it almost makes it seem like a stunt
weirdly i mean i'm not being
conspiratorial in any way
place very dangerous place and
it will continue i guess for a period of
time
differently about your personal safety
inside the white house no i feel very
safe with
secret service they're fantastic people
they're the best of the best
and they're highly trained
i don't know if anybody got to walk
outside but
there were a lot of terrific looking
people ready to go perfectly looking
something was necessary
wow people at the highest level of law
enforcement there's top nobody
like these people so they just wanted me
to step aside
for a little while just to make sure
that everything was cleared outside
because it was right in this area
mr president why did you decide after
that because obviously it created a lot
of commotion what made you decide to
come back and continue the briefing
propaganda think about not coming back i
said am i able to go back and they said
you'd have to wait a little while i
waited a little while as you know
in the oval office area and
i said can i get back now and they said
yes and they have
what a hero a lot of fortification
outside justin what a hero
it was one person okay
he said the shooting was outside how far
away from they're going to be giving you
a full briefing
in a little while for the white house or
was it right i can only tell you they're
going to give you a briefing
it was outside of the premises near the
fence but outside of the process so
pretty close to here
pretty close so i was telling you that
the dow jones
and the s p 500 are now 50 percent above
the march level nasdaq
is uh setting your records it's already
broken the record despite
the situation of having the china virus
we have
new jobs arising and unemployment is
falling faster than
nearly anyone thought and over the past
three months we've created over nine
million jobs
and that's a record a three-month record
have you added up
it's a three month record by far and
we've beaten
expectations by 12 million
or 12 million above expectations
which is pretty remarkable net jobs of
course still down dramatically
reports on new job openings and there's
clearly a housing boom which has been
incredible numbers in both housing
and an automobile boom we've rarely seen
anything like it and it's going on right
now in america
inventories are at rock bottom used car
sales are at record levels
and we will have rebuilt we're doing
a rebuilding like nobody's ever seen
it's a big plus for
manufacturing and construction so
construction's
getting close to record territory
manufacturing is doing very well the car
companies are doing great
very happy for michigan the state of
michigan we have a lot of car companies
moving in a lot of plants are being
built and expanded in michigan and
ohio there is no reason why the
economy can't grow at a 20 pace in the
third quarter that would be a record
and interestingly it'll be a uh a number
that's going so
it would be a record but the 32 percent
that it contracted is
the bigger record right so remember that
very interesting but it's it's going to
grow at a very substantial pace based on
all of the numbers we're looking at
and probably a lot more substantial than
we originally thought
we're creating new incentives for
working jobs and we're also providing
much needed assistance to those who
are still suffering from the effects of
the
pandemic contraction and the contraction
is now
uh well we have the pandemic we have a
lot of
great things happening in terms of the
vaccines and therapeutics as you know
and
i think we'll be making tremendous
progress over the next
period of a few months and certainly
before the end of the year i think we'll
have a
vaccine before the end of the year very
substantially and we may have
a therapeutic resolvement very quickly
very very quickly and frankly that's the
one i'd rather have faster
because you'd go in you'd give a
transfusion or a shot
to people that are very ill and they'd
be able to come out of the hospital
some plasma the next day or a few days
later
if the states participate in our core
sharing unemployment plan
we are going to be doing something
very very interesting with all of the
things that we announced on saturday i
have to repeat what they are you know
very well and
we've had we've had some tremendous
success already if you look at what's
happening with the stock market and
people are very thrilled at what we're
doing
we'd like to get the democrats to focus
on other than
what they're focusing on which is a
bailout of
poorly running states we have many great
running states
states that are setting records and uh
records let's see what happens with
respect to that
but the uh we're looking at also
considering a capital gains tax cut
which would create
a lot more jobs so we're looking very
seriously at a capital gains tax cut
and also uh joe biden looking at a
capital gains tax
increase so we're really getting into
some significant differences on economic
policy social security
capital gains a lot of very significant
differences particularly for
middle-income families and you'll be
hearing about that in the upcoming
few weeks and i think it'll be very
exciting so
a capital gains tax is going to be
a lot of a lot of people put to work and
it would be a cut in the capital gains
tax and also
capital gains tax does not create jobs
by the way we can do the economics later
so i now want to just discuss a little
quick brief and then we'll take a few
more questions
but uh we took some who would have known
we were going to take questions
before we started right they're right
jennifer
but uh that's the way it happens
sometimes we want to discuss if
we might the china virus and the world
continues its fight
against this horrible plague countries
in every continent are seeing increases
in cases
we have a rapid increase only in cases
where it's very interesting because
we're so far ahead of testing
we have more cases if we had much
smaller testing would have fewer but we
feel that having testing is a very
important thing
idiotic phrase idiotic statement in many
ways we
we've tested i guess close to 65 million
people
right now and nobody's even close to
that number
no other country is close india would be
second at 11 million we're still doing
this huh and they have 1.5 billion
people
so we uh we have the number one testing
anywhere in the world by far
and we also have i think the highest
quality test we have a lot of different
ones but we have the highest quality
including
the short term and the lab tests the lab
tests take a little bit longer
and dr burks was telling me a little
while ago that
uh we're down to two days and two and a
half days on
getting your result on the lab test the
other ones you get them in five minutes
to 15 minutes
right but you don't really because the
machines are so overwhelmed they can
still take five to seven days to get
your results
cases in recent days cases have rapidly
increased in japan and australia
unfortunately
and they're now experiencing higher
peaks than they did in march
to the south of a border of our border
cases have continued to surge in mexico
central america argentina colombia peru
brazil
and throughout latin america it's really
the hot spot
it's posing a major challenge for
this continent latin america is now the
region with the
most number of confirmed cases by far
despite a
relative scarcity of testing so notice
that now he's grouping countries
okay pretty much on fire having a hard
time and we're helping them we're
sending them tremendous numbers of
ventilators which we're making by the
thousands every month
and we're helping latin america very
much it's hard for
them to come into the country because we
have big sections of wall up now the new
wall is being built which people don't
talk about
they used to talk about nothing but the
wall now that it's being built
they're not talking about it so much but
it's helped us because we're up to
almost we're getting close to 280 miles
280 miles in the most important areas
last week it was like 400 miles the
numbers don't matter it's all lies
not having people come in to the country
who are
infected with the coronavirus
this global trend underscores the
persistence of the virus including the
nations that
apply the strictest and most punishing
lockdowns you have nations that are
really tough on the lockdowns and
they're getting hit very hard
that's why my administration is pursuing
a science-based approach that protects
the most vulnerable
preserves hospital capacity and focuses
on the delivery and development of
treatments and ultimately the vaccine
i feel strongly that we will have a
vaccine by
the end of the year and it'll be put in
service
maybe even as we get it because we're
all set militarily we're using our
military to
distribute the vaccine and logistically
there's nobody like this group of people
i meet with them a lot and they're ready
to go
as soon as they have it they'll be going
but
more importantly uh the therapeutics as
i said i think the therapeutics could be
great initially speaking i think that
would be if i had my choice but you can
have them both
you can have them both you can have them
both very soon too
at the same time we urge all americans
to apply common sense
mitigation you all know what that
mitigation is everybody knows it by
heart now
nearly half of all of the deaths from
the china virus in the united states
have occurred in nursing homes and
long-term care facilities
that's why we have delivered funding
equipment and rapid testing to our
nation's
nursing homes to protect those at high
risk
we're very focused on nursing homes and
senior citizens areas
anywhere that we have senior citizens
who are very very focused
we've delivered over 1 800 rapid
point-of-care testing devices those are
very quick
and shipped over 700 000 tests to
nursing homes
nursing homes are being protected like
never before the united states faces a
unique range of challenges that requires
our constant vigilance
america has the largest at-risk
population of any developed country
by far 1.5 million residents of nursing
homes about five times out of the united
kingdom and other european countries
our country also has a higher prevalence
of
underlying conditions at this virus
targets that is true
yet we have fewer deaths per capita than
the united kingdom
and most other peer nations in western
europe
so that's an important we have fewer
deaths we have fewer deaths per capita
than the uk
but we're still like 10th highest in the
world remember that
heading for even stronger numbers but
one person is too much as far as i'm
concerned should have never been allowed
to happen
should have never been allowed to escape
china nationwide
we continue to see encouraging signs in
the last seven days
nationwide cases declined by 14
hospitalizations decreased by 7
fatalities decreased by 9 arizona and
florida
are improving rapidly with fewer
patients coming to emergency rooms by
far
as well as decreasing cases decreasing
fatalities unexpected
and expanded hospital capacities so
we have an expanded hospital capacity
it's uh it's pretty dramatic when you
look at it
meaning we have more room should we need
it
so a lot of tremendous work has been
done in texas likewise the number of
patients
going to emergency rooms has dropped
from july
by more than two-thirds that's a lot
nevertheless we continue to monitor
texas
very closely terrific governor terrific
people working on that
whole situation in texas especially
at its test positivity rate
which rose over 20 percent this weekend
overall cases in texas are coming down
and have stabilized
in the border counties that's again
where you have
the wall and you're next to uh in in
some cases the wall in some cases you'll
have it very shortly you'll have it all
the wall is decreasing the number of
cases yeah
but those areas were hit very hard and
they're
likely cases from mexico that come in
back and forth from the border they come
in illegally as doctors have found more
effective ways to treat patients the
fatality rate continues to improve
texas has won six the fatality rate of
new york and new jersey that they had
different populations that that's maybe
one of the dumbest comparisons
since the start of this density and
a lot of different kinds of difficulty
the fatality rates in florida and
arizona are between 25 and 33 percent of
the peak rates
of new york i think he's also comparing
case fatality rates
in texas versus new i mean that i i am
hard pressed to think of a less
meaningful
comparison you could make in california
the situation is starting to stabilize
and improve throughout the major
metropolitan areas statewide
hospitalizations continue to decline
very substantially with about 20 percent
fewer
in patients now than on july 21st
california is starting to really show
signs of uh
correcting we're monitoring regions with
increasing cases including boston
chicago
and the midwest and we're monitoring
them very very strongly and
strong very very hard a hard one to say
that
i think at the end of a fairly short
period of time you're going to be in
very very good shape
all over our country every loss of life
is tragic and all nations must work
together to defeat this horrible
virus my administration is going to
continue to save as many lives as
possible
we are working round the clock everybody
i mean it's
incredible how hard they're working and
he golfed all weekend folks
trees we're working with them also and
they're working very hard this is
something
that's now attacked 188 different
countries
there are a wide range of factors that
determine how the virus impacts a nation
such as age underlining conditions
underlining
underlying conditions is a very big one
are you
if you're sick in any way if you're if
especially they say heart and diabetes
that's not a good
thing to have if you
if you're going to have this if you're
going to catch it so we're trying to
protect especially those people that
have
problems with their heart or diabetes
and levels of pre-existing immunity
resulting from
past exposure to other viruses which
happens
we must stop politicizing the virus and
instead be
united in our stop okay
how this virus came to america how this
virus came to the world
and we're going to figure it out and
we're going to find out
and we're very angry about it on the
therapeutics and
vaccine updates three vaccine candidates
are currently in
phase three clinical trials something
that would have been impossible under
the previous administration or any other
completely untrue and several others are
showing considerable promise
we have great companies very well-known
companies i think everyone in this room
would know these companies but they're
the biggest and the best in the world
and we're working with uh other
foreign companies and countries that
have
have been really working very closely
with us we're trading we're not looking
to uh
do anything but come up with the answer
and we really don't we don't care we
want to come up with the answer
if it's one of ours or one of theirs
it's okay we have to come up with the
answer and we're
very close to getting it some people
think we have it either way trump will
take credit for it so who cares where it
comes from
best scientists in the world racing to
develop a safe vaccine that will end
this pandemic
save millions of lives and that's
millions of lives all over the world
and end the harm inflicted by this virus
to our society and
to all other nations last week the nih
began a clinical trial of
rem de severe paired with another
approved antiviral drug an
anti-inflammatory drug you know that
rem deserver has been very successful
and now they're experimenting with
others
including antivirals and
anti-inflammatories
and they're having some very interesting
success
we've secured enough remdesseviere to
treat over 650 000 patients
on saturday i took executive action
in its signing to save american jobs and
support american workers i signed
directives to give a payroll tax
holiday with the understanding that
after the election on the assumption
that would be
victorious for an administration that's
done a great job
uh we will be ending that tax we'll be
terminating that tax
so a little bit of a buying of votes in
a way
that will kneecap funding for social
security understand i do i have a
segment about this so i won't spend a
lot of time on it if he
if he does this social security is
getting cut
doing it and we intend to terminate
terminated at the end of the appropriate
period of time
it's for those making less than one
hundred thousand dollars to the end of
twenty twenty
to provide an extra four hundred dollars
per week
also in unemployment benefits and to
extend the freeze on home evictions
we want to extend the freeze so people
aren't evicted it's not their fault that
the
virus came from china it's china's fault
and to suspend payments
on student loans through the end of the
year and then beyond
then again you know they're paying
interest on loans and and they're not
allowed to go to their
college so we're going to suspend
payments
on student loans through the end of the
year and then another extension most
likely because it's not fair to the
students to
hopefully he'll be gone by then though
the colleges aren't doing
the job of getting open and i think
probably many of them could be open so
i want to thank you all i'm sorry for
the disturbance before
things happen and uh if you'd like we'll
take a few questions yeah
thank you mr president i appreciate it
um kaylee said earlier today that you've
been working around the clock
so there's no delay to get these um
investment unemployment payments to
america that was a lie
can you give me your timetable are we
talking next week two weeks a month
so mr secretary you're saying when i
think within the next
week or two most of the states will be
able to execute
got it and by the way the gentleman you
know everybody you know russell
you know but this is scott atlas you
know that
scott is a very famous man who's uh
also very uh highly respected stanford
and he's working with us and we have no
idea who he is on the coronavirus
and he has many great ideas and
he thinks what we've done is really good
and now we'll take it to a new level
and so hoover institutions working along
with us and we appreciate it very much
thank you very much really we've had
some great
you discussions the states have all the
governors sign
on to this uh we just had a meeting with
the governors and they were
very anxious to get money for the people
in their states
and if they depending on the state we
have the right to do
what we want to do we can terminate the
25 percent
uh or we don't have to do that so we'll
see what it is
depends on the individual state but a
lot of money will be going to a lot of
people very quickly
and i've instructed the secretary of the
treasury to
move as quickly as he can right so we'll
get it done yeah please
i wanted to just ask you to be clear on
the incident outside
there's a fairly significant perimeter
around the white house it doesn't
concern you at all that someone who was
armed was able to get
so close that you needed to be removed
from the briefing room well i don't know
if he was close or not he or she
i don't think they were close it was he
or she but
i have such confidence in these people
they're so good
and i don't think the person breached
anything
it was on the outside ground so i don't
believe anything was breached i asked
that question so
they were relatively far away
97 000 children tested positive for
coronavirus in the last two weeks in
july according to the
american academy of pediatrics does that
give you any pause about
schools reopening for in person no
because
they may have as you would call it a
case it may be a case but it's
also a case where there's a tiny it's a
tiny
sniffle of death
tiny fraction and uh
they get better very quickly yeah they
have they may have it for a short period
of time but that
as you know the the seriousness of it in
terms of
what it leads to is is extraordinarily
small very very much less
than one percent believe that children
are essentially yeah i think that for
the most part they do very well i mean
they
don't get very sick they don't catch it
easily they don't get
very not true according to the people
that i've spoken to they don't
transport it or transfer it to
transparent other people
uh or certainly not very easily so
yeah i think schools have to open we
want to get our
economy going we have incredible numbers
despite this
if we could get this going i think it's
a very important thing for the economy
to get the schools
going jonathan thank you mr president uh
in ohio a few days ago
you said quote joe biden has hurt god
he's against god um the vice president
has said that he's a man of deep
catholic faith that he's
credited for helping him endure some
immense personal tragedy
so sir what did you mean by that and you
said that joe biden has hurt
that they've come up with and if you
look at their stance on
religion and things having to do very
importantly with
aspects of religion and faith i don't
think a
man of deep religion so no examples
sanders plan you take a look at what
they have in and you just
you can't put that into the realm of
a religious group of people i will say
that
and i think it's one of the reasons why
if you look at polls which
i'm not a big believer in polls nope
wouldn't if i was i guess i wouldn't be
standing here right now
and by the way our poll numbers are
going up very rapidly
so you do believe those polls okay oh
it's interesting i don't believe in
polls and our poll numbers are going up
quick
so because that uh you know it's one of
those things but no if you look at
uh the manifesto i call it the manifesto
a lot of people are calling it the
manifesto
my opinion it's further left than where
bernie was before so normally he'd be
left and you'd bring it somewhere a
little bit toward the center
but some of the things that they have
down there and i'm not
only talking completely untrue talking
even
in terms of religion but some of the
things they have in the agreement made
no examples still made by bernie sanders
and
joe it's a terrible thing it would be a
terrible thing for our country
it will destroy our country we will go
into a depression
we will could you give one example
double and triple taxes
we will obviously taxes aren't being
tripled or doubled
you'll have 180 million people lose
their health care
it will be a terrible terrible thing for
us 30 more million will get health care
all right i'd like to ask you a question
about something you said in fedminster
as well
he said that you're planning to issue an
executive order to
ensure that health insurance companies
prevent or cover people with
pre-existing conditions and you said
that that had never been done before but
that's
that's not the case because that is the
law under the affordable care act yes
so my question is why do you need to
issue an executive order for
i said as an executive order i as you
said
no one's ever done it executive order it
hasn't been done before
no one's done it by executive order but
it's still the law to
assure people that pre-existing
condition is always
taken care of as you know we've done
no one's ever outlawed murder by
executive order
individual mandate from obamacare which
really ended obamacare as it would be
officially known because a delightful
mandate was the biggest part
it was also the most unpopular part drug
dealing isn't illegal
by executive order we're paying for
insurance you pay not to have to pay for
your health care
and that was a disaster for people at a
very unpopular that was
called the individual mandate and we
terminated that
and officially terminated that and that
was something that
we have been given uh thanks for by many
many people
but the individual mandate will always
be
with us the the individual mandate
termination will always be they can't
start it up
in fact i don't even believe you'll have
to tell me i don't believe it's been
challenged when we ended it
and pre-existing conditions the
republicans are
100 percent there it's already the law
be
uh issuing at some point in the not too
distant future
a very strong statement on that probably
in the form of
an her to do executive order order if
it's already a part of it just a double
safety net and just to let people know
that the republicans are totally
strongly in favor of do murder i mean if
you're really against murder
we can't just leave it to the law we we
need an executive order we got to do
that is he not against murder because
he's only leaving it to the law
it's a second platform we have
pre-existing conditions will be taken
care of 100 percent
by republicans and the republican party
i think it's a
i actually think it's a very important
statement it's meaningless president do
you
still intend to try to hold an in-person
g7 meeting uh in the united states at
some point in august and september and
have you already sent out invitations to
do so we haven't sent out invitations
we're talking to them as you know i was
on the phone with many of them yesterday
with respect to lebanon
which is truly one of the saddest most
catastrophic things i've ever seen
and they have no idea how many people
have died they're having
revolution right now in that country
it's uh just a terrible thing
and but i was yesterday eight o'clock in
the morning we had an
hour time we had a a big teleconference
call
some of those people were there i i'm
much more inclined to do it sometime
after the election
we were going to do it in september
they'd like to do it
we could do it through teleconference or
we could do it through a meeting but
i i sort of am now suggesting i told my
people
yesterday actually uh why don't we do it
sometime
after the election when things are
a little bit uh it could be awkward you
have a little more time to think about
it because it's very important
the g7 is very important uh to that
meeting
uh i don't know but we have invited a
number of people to the meeting
i certainly would invite him to the
meeting i think he's an important factor
but uh we will invite certain people
that aren't in the g7
certain some people have already
accepted but we're going to be doing it
after the election i think it's a better
atmosphere to have a g7
i think it's a lot uh i think it's
just a better calmer atmosphere to have
a g7 yeah please uh i wanted to ask
secretary
you should actually uh have you spoken
to any democrats since friday or they
reached out to you at all about
restarting negotiations
i have not spoken to schumer and pelosi
we're more than happy to meet they're
hurting people very badly this would
have been so easy for them to do
and i saw that senator schumer said
today on
a show i don't know what show but he
said today on the show that
we should meet we should do something
but you know where has he been for how
many
weeks have you been negotiating like
four and uh
remember democrats put out a proposal
two months ago doing it the way we did
it but we did something that's
uh very important and frankly it's been
well received very well received go
ahead please
mr president you tweeted earlier today
that you're considering
gettysburg as a venue for your speech
for the rnc nomination acceptance
what's your thinking behind that as a
possible location what's this thing i
think it's
delusions of grandeur numerous times
it's a national park it's a national
historic site
it's incredible you know it's the
history
it's incredible actually to me uh
it was a very important place and is a
very important place in our country so
we're looking at that
and we're looking at the white house the
white house would be
very much easier for secret service you
see
what just went on here right they're all
here
just like you have your seats they have
their seats at the white house
so there wouldn't be any expense or any
extraordinary expense
trump cares about that that's why he's
only golfed 287 times so far
do it all so least expensive place that
you could do it would be at the white
house
this is a government a government
expense and i
you know look i i watch also with
governments i watch to make sure that
we do what's right but we're looking at
gettysburg and we're looking at the
white house and
we have other sites too but i think
these would be two really beautiful sets
jennifer
would you envision having an audience
for that speech
you could you have plenty of room at
both locations i see john roberts john
uh you were outside you said you heard
shots fired before
two shots in rapid succession just after
you picked the phone
and they were shots pretty much
certainly you definitely know the
difference i know that
that's you know the difference i you
thought they were shots john
definitely sounded like i saw your
report inside when i went inside
uh it's a good report too thank you very
much appreciate it
this is a good report can you give us an
update on china
do you think that your administration
will respond to the sanctions that china
announced this morning
on american officials well we've already
responded in many different ways we're
we're uh talking a lot about china
we shouldn't have been talking about
china we did a phase one deal and it was
a wonderful deal and
all of a sudden it means very little in
the overall
import of things they should have never
allowed what happened to the world
including us but this was released into
europe and it was released into the u.s
it was released all throughout the world
but it wasn't released into china
and we were doing numbers that will you
know just were incredible and we hope to
be able to do them
perhaps even next year i think we're
going to have an incredible year next
year but
that will never pay for the loss of life
in our country and all over the world so
we are
we view china differently than we did
eight months ago
very much differently yes please is
there still any consideration of
de-listing chinese
companies is that an ongoing discussion
d-listing de-listing chinese companies
we never comment on specific things but
no there's nothing in it
i never comment on specific things again
nothing specifically at the moment are
you talking about de-listing
oh comments on the exchange yes oh i'm
sorry yes so
just to be clear we we did make the
recommendation
and the sec will be putting out yes as
as of
the end of next year if they do not
fully comply and that's chinese
companies any other companies they all
have to comply with the same exact
accounting
where they will be de-listed on the
exchanges
cringe and jennifer we're also talking
on the
wto the world trade organization
china is treated much differently than
we are
this should have been handled many years
ago when it first happened but they are
treated as a
as a nation that's developing they're
treated as what they call a developing
nation which gives them tremendous
incentives and advantages over and above
what the united states gets and
over above what other countries get also
this is a developing nation i don't
think so i don't think for purposes of
what we're talking about it should be
and we are putting in and we've already
put in a request that
china should no longer be declared a
developing nation and have advantages
over
the u.s and i told them that a year ago
and i told them that two years ago
trump certainly has a lot of requests
for what needs to happen to other
countries
over other countries frankly and sure
they're not going to have any more
advantages over this should have been
done by
numerous presidents a long time ago
because it gives them a tremendous
a tremendous boost over everybody else
and it's a very unfair situation
no we are upset with china because of
what they did
china was not good and china weird
glitch on china there
if you look at what's going to happen
whether it's iran
iran will make a deal with us in a month
after the election election's over if we
win the election but the
greatest dream in the world is that joe
biden wins because they will own this
country
china will own this country north korea
will own this country they will own our
country
and they're all waiting to see the
election and if we make a
if we have a win in on november 3rd we
will
uh have a deal with in my opinion iran
within one month
and i don't know that we want to have a
deal with china it's great all the stuff
that's going to happen
right after he's re-elected free money
for people through making permanent
payroll tax deferrals deals deals up the
wazoo right november 5th he's going to
have everything done for us
stories about russia it was just
reported the numbers
i raised 400 billion dollars extra
in nato you know that it went from 130
to 400 billion
and that's a year in order to
strengthen up nato nobody says that we
became the biggest
energy exporter we are now if you look
at what we have we're energy independent
so many different things our military
is stronger than it ever was we spent
2.5 trillion dollars on our military
i exposed the terrible deal between
germany and
russia on the pipeline nobody even knew
about the pipeline nordstrom nordstrom
2.
nobody knew about it nobody talks about
it i said what's this all about so we
protect
germany from russia and germany pays
russia billions of dollars a year for
energy and it's a big portion of
germany's energy
right if i was a person that was a
german citizen i would not be happy with
that deal
because they're at a very big
disadvantage so uh
no russia would not be happy and i can
tell you that china would not be happy
at all
we've taken in tens of billions of
dollars as you're head of the
treasury steve right we've taken in tens
of billions of years that's
right china we never took 10 cents from
china never
not even 10 cents and 28 billion dollars
we gave to our farmers because they were
targeted by china
they were actually targeted and we gave
28 billion dollars
compliments of china to our great
farmers
and ranchers because they were unfairly
targeted by china
in order to make a better deal with us i
said we're not going to do that we're
going to instead of making a better deal
we're going to tear a few
we're going to make a worse very high
numbers 25 10
and actually numbers that could go up a
lot and uh
yeah the is this still related to the
question asked about mnuchin
of mnuchin about delisting i can't even
remember the question at this point we
uh
we had many many billions of dollars
left
and we're still receiving that money
even though we made the deal we're still
receiving thank you very much everybody
so if uh if we win the election we'll
have deals with
a lot of countries very fast they're
just waiting to see who wins because
they are hoping
they are hoping that joe biden wins
sleepy joe and if he wins you know
what's going to happen so they're hoping
your opponent wins but they'll make
deals with you right after he loses
makes sense
the 401ks will go down to practically
nothing
zero down to practically nothing zero
stocks
these big companies they're owned by
millions of people
that are gold will be worthless if biden
wins
farmers and lots of other people and and
they are the ones that benefit by having
a good stock market probably more than
anybody else
but the 401ks the stocks the economy
will be
in shambles they want to raise taxes
they want to triple
taxes yeah they're going to go from 37
percent
to 103 percent apparently they can't pay
for what they want to do anyway and what
they're going to do is
destroy your health care and destroy so
many other things we're going to have
180
million people that are so happy with
their private health care they're going
to lose it
under this crazy plan that these people
are proposing so
you will have a crash like you've never
seen before and i've been very
like the coronavirus crash doing these
things yeah please guys thank you thank
you
uh you just mentioned uh president putin
and the possibility of inviting him here
because he's important
um your own director of national
intelligence has said that russia is
currently planning or actually meddling
in the election
have you raised that directly within i
don't know they said
china russia iran and probably
others but because of the fake news they
seem to think russia plays the best so
yeah
so what they do it's all right well i'm
just saying the way i'll be covering
this in detail tomorrow
said the three countries they said china
and russia and iran and some reporter
got up and said
russia is meddling i said well didn't it
mention china and iran why didn't you
mention them too
so so i don't know you know what i'm
telling you i'll tell you who's meddling
in our elections
the democrats are meddling by wanting
and insisting on sending mail-in ballots
kneecapping the post office does that
count as meddling is that election fraud
anybody
all relatively small race with carolyn
maloney
and they called her the winner the other
day because i was mentioning it at
conferences and getting
there's no fraud even alleged in that
race they called her they declared her
the winner
and they have no idea who won and the
person her opponent is very angry
but they had mail-in voting and they had
hundreds and
i think even thousands of ballots that
are missing
that were fraudulent take a look at the
carolyn maloney race there is no
allegation of
fraudulent ballots in that race now with
this one in virginia where they mailed
out
500 000 applications and they go into
people that
aren't supposed to be getting
applications applications
right not to europe ballots this week
do you have any updates on when the
travel restrictions for the eu are going
to be listed
it seems strange we're offering
exemptions for professional athletes
but not the k1 visa holders the
so-called we try and do the best we can
you have big
sporting events and that's good for our
economy that's good for us and they do
uh talk about certain exemptions and
they make sure everyone's perfectly
tested and everyone comes in
but you know we do make certain
accommodations because you do have star
athletes and that means a good thing for
the country that's economic development
etc uh but we are working very closely
with europe and with other countries to
see what's the best timing don't forget
i was the one that
turned europe off because they really uh
they led the way they left
shut off the faucet that was europe
months following them
and uh in terms of they got hit earlier
than we did quite a bit earlier than we
did
so i put the restrictions on europe i
put the restrictions on china which was
a great thing to do in retrospect
we're getting i mean that's that was a
very important day dr fauci said that
was one of the most
important days and a lot of people
didn't want me but we first put
ban a ban on anybody from china coming
in and then we put
a ban on europe coming in but we're
working very closely with europe to see
when that will all come off yeah please
if 160 000 people had died on president
obama's watch do you think you would
have called for his resignation
no i wouldn't have done that i think
it's uh
i think it's been amazing what we've
been able to do if we didn't close up
didn't he call for obama's resignation
based on two ebola deaths
people already did we've called it right
now we don't have to close it we
understand the disease nobody understood
it because
nobody's ever seen anything like this
the closest thing is uh
in 1917 they say right the
the great 1980s great pandemic certainly
was a terrible thing where they lost
anywhere from 50 to 100 million people
probably ended the second world war all
the soldiers were sick
it was a that was a terrible situation
and
this is highly contagious this one is
highly highly contagious
now if i would have listened to a lot of
people we would have kept it open
and by the way we keep it open i've
never heard by the way a hundred million
people died i
i heard 17 to 30 million i don't know if
anybody knows about that one and a half
to two million people
uh our people have done a fantastic jobs
our
consultants and our doctors you know and
with disagreements and with
a lot of things happening what we've
done with ventilators has been amazing
what we've done with
medical equipment has been incredible
we've supplied the governor's nobody not
one person
in this country that needed a ventilator
didn't get it
and you know at the beginning there was
a big shortage of ventilators nobody had
stockpiles or anything
comparable wasn't it
we would have lost if you think about it
you had mentioned 160 000
people multiply that times 10 right now
i think it would have been unsustainable
and unacceptable what
but that's what would have happened had
we now he's saying 16 million people
would have died
he's never even suggested that before
what
one person i said all the time a lot of
people like to leave that out
one person is too many it should have
never happened
but they've done a what really an
extraordinary job they'll never be given
the credit and i'm not talking about me
the people hold on he said multiply it
by a hundred didn't he say
160 000 times 100 would be 16 million or
did he not just say multiply it by a
hundred governors who as you know
they sort of do the micro oh he said ten
oh oh my god
they go up and i think i can tell you
that i stand correct sorry
extraordinary job too yeah please go
ahead thank you did you ask
the u.s ambassador in brazil to focus
his
efforts in uh eliminating ethanol
tariffs
in brazil you have to you can't yeah
the ambassador in brazil to focus his
efforts to lower to eliminate
ethanol tariffs in brazil we haven't
really discussed that too much but
at some point we probably will be he
didn't hear it but the answer is no
people tariffing us and if they tariff
us although i must tell you have a very
good
relationship with president bolsonaro
he's great he's and i hear he's doing
well he literally recovered from
having coveted having coveted 19 as they
say
and that's great and send in my regards
i think that as far as brazil is
concerned if they do
tariffs we have to have an equalization
of tariffs and we
we are going to be presenting something
having to do with tariffs and fairness
and
tariffs because we have many countries
for many years that have been charging
us tariffs
to do business and we don't judge them
and it's called
reciprocity it's called reciprocal
tariffs
and uh you may be seeing something on
that very soon did you have one oh yeah
o-a-n of course o-a-n please thank you
mr president first of all thank you for
coming back
to finish the briefing thank you very
much after the uh scuffle
um so i have an opinion question for you
joe biden is set to announce his running
mate
at any time now we expect him to
announce
her um many of your supporters
feel that the reason that obama's former
nsa
susan rice brace herself
is that she can best cover up a lot of
the obama gate surveillance crimes
during your campaign what are your
thoughts what is your opinion
this guy's like what is this girl
talking about obama campaign
spied on our campaign and they've been
caught
untrue and now let's see what happens to
them but
they have been caught they've been
caught red-handed
it's probably treason it's a horrible
thing they did
it probably never happened before at
least nobody
got caught doing it but they used the
intelligence agencies of our country
to spy on my campaign and they have been
caught treason
and there are a lot of people involved
i don't want to say how much she's
involved frankly if he chooses her
that's fine but that's
a potential liability we'll see but
president obama knew about it joe biden
knew about
it uh comey
knew about it i hope you all know this
is brennan clap imaginary whole group
they all knew about it lisa page and
peter lover struck they all knew about
it
and we have it documented we have it in
texts we have it in
all sorts of forms i knew about it it
was a terrible thing should have never
happened and should never be allowed to
happen again
to a president this should never happen
again this was
a setup like we have never seen i think
it's the political crime of the century
and they've been caught so let's see
what happens thank you very much
thank you very much thank you thank you
thank you
wow oh man i i am exhausted
from this complete and utter
insanity um thanks to robin
eckles and liam elliott i don't want to
forget you guys i appreciate
you signing up uh on the way out please
remember on youtube
hit that subscribe button we are in a
battle and it is a fierce battle to a
million youtube subscribers
we're just about to roll over to 932 000
so please do hit subscribe on the way
out it's free
and you'll be notified about future
streams
uh everybody watching on twitch you guys
are not chopped liver
okay we are on the way to 50 000
followers on twitch
and i hope you also will follow me i'll
be back tomorrow
clips streams the entire thing
my lighting will be improved i'll see
everybody then
streams the entire thing my lighting
will be improved i'll see